ils centaine d'artistes se produiront
cette fin de semaine au festival osheaga
mais si on veut dire les artistes
masculin et les groupes mixtes de la
programmation on se retrouve avec une
affiche
allégé de 75 % sinon osheaga est loin
d'être le seul festival à ne pas
atteindre la parité en 2019 seulement
23% des artistes se produire dans les
festivals québécois étaient des femmes
je pense qu'on prend le problème parce
que c'est encore un problème n'est pas
cette femme du mauvais sens pourquoi il
n'y a pas autant de femmes sur les
affiches mais parce qu'au départ elles
ne sont pas accompagnées de la même
façon pour qu'une fausse hollande sur
une affiche le festival les focales et
en disque et il faut qu'elle ait
performer des jeunes qu'elle ait des
jeux du galon bien qu'elles soient
conscientes de l'enjeu
elle estime que la réalité de
l'industrie ne permet pas d'atteindre
actuellement la panique
est-ce qu'on cause les cases constamment
non on est dans l'arctique les
inégalités ne sont pas propres à
certains genres musicaux par exemple il
ce n'est qu'avec 8 % d'artistes
féminines se trouve loin derrière mutek
igloofest où les piknic électronik qui
sont au dessus de la moyenne avec 2 23 à
30 % de femmes
c'est comme une route c'est je comprends
les programmateurs de dire il pas assez
d'offres féminine en fait ils font
partie aussi des du problème parce que
ce temps qu'on n'envoie pas des femmes
sur les grandes scènes n'y a pas de
femmes qui se disent qu'ils peuvent la
france
la chanteuse annie hall 2 parce que les
programmateurs doivent être plus curieux
mais il croit également qu'il faut un
changement de mentalité ni ya plusieurs
réalités du de cette job lot cette
carrière là qui sont content est
défavorable à la longévité comme d'une
femme en musique c'est si je pense par
exemple aux matériaux pvc plus capter le
toujours être par l'alcool toujours être
temps des visites pas possible de
tourner un petit corps dans un bain je
pense que des fois il ya des chances et
mon dieu c'est pas quelque chose que je
veux faire les organisateurs de mutek se
sont engagées concrètement avec des
initiatives comme kit change et un pli
faille des initiatives qui visent à
augmenter le nombre de femmes dans les
festivals soit que les fans sont prêts
c'est qu'ils sont peu visibles donc
fouillé tout un travail qu'on doit faire
lors seulement de porter attention
de creuser pour trouver les femmes il
faut s'y faire de la place pour que les
femmes se rapporte
il se sente confortable dans cet
environnement là établir des quatorze
revoir le financement des festivals
soutenir le développement professionnel
des femmes artistes ces quelques unes
des pistes de solutions évoquées mais
tous les intervenants s'accordent pour
dire qu'il n'ya pas de solution simple
et c'est l'abbé alexandre chartier radio
canada montréal